arnold schwarzenegger uh stopped by
jimmy kimmel live where he gushed all
about being a grandpa after jimmy
congratulated him on his daughter
catherine expecting another child with
her husband chris pratt bye
you're gonna be a grandfather again for
the second time your daughter katherine
her husband chris pratt
have blessed you with yet another child
on the way it's on the way and they tell
you one thing that it is the easiest
thing
to be a grandfather why do you say that
oh i'm telling you because they come
over to the house
you know you play with the with lyla for
around an hour or two i put them on the
horse i put them with the dog i play
with the dog and after two hours they
leave
oh well that's it that's fantastic i
tell you so it's uh i i have a great
time and to come over to the house just
you know you you're friends with chris
pratt he's a fantastic guy he is a great
guy son-in-law i love my daughter
catherine is so wonderful and i'm so
proud of her so they're great you know
when they come over the whole house
lights up and uh the animals are there
and they are there and we play with the
uh yeah it's like the baby jesus yeah